inicio la carrera de electoral y
nicaragua cientos de nicaragüenses
fueron convocados a este fin de semana a
verificar su identidad para votar en las
elecciones
el sacerdote edwin román asistió en la
localidad que le corresponde pese a que
tiene sus dudas del proceso de cárabo
todavía me condiciones para para ir a
elecciones sabemos que hay una cantidad
de presos políticos entre ellos lo
posible candidato no hay libertad para
una marcha para que los ciudadanos te
pueden arrestar libremente hay muchas
condiciones que todavía no están listas
para que los nicaragüense vayamos a una
elecciones y es que el proceso tuvo
lugar mientras opositores denunciaban el
arresto domiciliario de noel vidaurre el
séptimo aspirante presidencial en manos
de la policía y la octava aspirante de
oposición la abogada maría asunción
moreno salida del país al conocer que
sería expresada
ante el acoso la persecución y la
amenaza de mi encarcelamiento por parte
de la dictadura ortega murillo he
decidido salir del país creo que desde
el duro exilio podría aportar más que
desde el aislamiento e incomunicación al
que son sometidos nuestros presos
políticos
daniel ortega que gobierna desde 2007 ha
manifestado que sus contrincantes a la
silla presidencial son delincuentes
hasta ahora más de 30 líderes han sido
privados de libertad y sus familiares
denuncian que no han podido verlos las
elecciones por ahora no tienen otro
posible candidato que el líder
sandinista en busca de su cuarta
reelección